so earlier today I had a visit with
every single one of my kids teachers
three kids I went to school they're all
going pretty much the same school and
had a sit-down with them and they're
giving me their assessment here's how
they're doing with reading math etc etc
and one of the kids was extremely
creative the teacher started sitting
down with me and telling me you know he
has a hard time following instructions
the first time and you know she started
briefing me on everything and he's not
doing this and he's not doing that he's
not do all the other kids were good but
this one kid you know he's not doing
this and he's not doing that he's not
doing this and the entire time I'm
listening to her all I'm thinking about
is what things were said about me when I
was his age at six years old when we
were living in Iran
I'd be kicked out of a Sunday School
classes every single time my teachers
would kick me out of class and they
would say you don't need to come here
because you keep asking about all these
questions if God loves people so much
why are we getting bombed down why are
we getting you know and these are not
the questions to ask at six years old my
kid is like that right and so I asked
the lady I said listen if I may my
biggest concern with my son is the fact
that I don't want him to think that just
because he's different from everybody
else that that is an issue and he said
what do you mean I said see he's not the
issue he said three different teachers
and one of the teachers didn't work out
I couldn't wait for her to no longer be
his teacher because she kept trying to
change him and she didn't like his
personality another teacher who was a I
mean gods same type of a teacher let me
tell you this lady she's absolutely
amazing one of her students died during
the year in the class and another kid
got cancer and another kid got cancer in
the same year Dallas newspaper came to
write an article about this class
because of the amount of tragedies and
challenges they went through and she led
the entire classroom she was amazing she
knew how to lead him and she know how to
communicate with them and she helped him
change not by forcing him to change
what's my point and what does this mean
to you why why are you watching this
when I'm telling you stories about my
kids
you know what did this stuff have to do
with you let me explain to what this has
to do with you people are going to try
to change you in two different ways okay
one there's gonna be people that want to
help you change your mindset you know
and change your mindset and the way you
view things that's a different story
but then there's gonna be people that
are gonna try to change you the way you
are with your personality and those
people that try to change you with your
personality on the way you're wired you
have to be very careful with that
because if you allow somebody to
convince you to change your personality
not your mindset you in a way could take
that as maybe you're not good enough and
it's BS it's complete BS have to battle
with the people that end up winning at
the highest level you know what they
have they end up believing that they can
win at the highest level that the way
they're wired is worthy enough to win at
the highest level that's the mindset
there are different personalities than
you I've seen people that are quiet
timid and people think they're weak and
they become presidents you've seen
people that are loud and very loud and
obnoxious and they become president so
it doesn't mean just one type of
personality once every type of
personality one just a mindset so don't
let anybody convince you that your
personality and the way your wiring is
not here here that has to change
that's not worthy enough what needs to
change is your mindset is the way you
view the world is the way you view
things money life marriage business
freedom relationships those processing
that you have here it's okay to change
those things but not your personality
your personality is perfect just the way
it is all the other things you can work
on so I did a video on this having to do
with personalities and one of the videos
I do was like four years ago on how to
deal with anxiety and as well as
depression because sometimes
entrepreneurs nowadays deal with anxiety
and depression click on a link over here
somewhere over here to go watch that if
you haven't watched it I did this for
years ago when I was going through it
and hopefully it'll give you some
insight for some of you that feel you
are not worthy enough to take your game
to the next level take everybody bye-bye